Vingt années que je suis dans le game
Et je sais que Mario sera toujours le favori
Le préféré, le numéro 1, mais bon, au fond de mon cœur ça ne me dérange pas...
FAUX !
Je ne suis plus gentil, Luigi sort la kalash'!
*bruits de tirs*
Pendant son sommeil j'vais lui refaire la moustache.
On verra bientôt qui sera le champion quand j'lui ferai avaler ses 200 champignons.
Mon kart est pourrave, il tombe toujours en panne ! J'peux pas tourner, j'me prend toutes les peaux de bananes.
Pour lui niquer sa race, j'lui pique une carapace
Moi j'veux qu'on case le mode kamikaze.
*explosion*
Comment voulez-vous que Mario soit le maître ?
Alors que ce mec mesure moins d'un mètre ?
Cette petite lopette s'habille en salopette
Alors que moi... Ah ouais moi aussi en fait
[Refrain]L.U.I.G.I : mon nom c'est Luigi
[Refrain]Here we, here we go : c'est la fin de Mario
Hé ouais, j'suis vénère ! J'dois m'habiller en vert
Avec cette couleur, on m'prend pour un éboueur.
Mario par-là, Mario par-ci.
Le perso' qu'on choisit ce n'est jamais Luigi.
Pourtant j'fais des efforts, Luigi fait du sport
J'ai un max de pecs, lui est gros comme un porc
Luigi's Mansion c'était ma carrière solo, mais en arme de tueur
Ils m'ont mis un aspirateur...
Hé ! Regardez la femme de ménage avec son aspirateur ! On fait la poussière ?
Hum, non non... Ouais.
[Refrain]L.U.I.G.I mon nom c'est Luigi ! Here we, here we go : c'est la fin de Mario [bis]
Je n'ai pas la peste, je n'suis pas boiteux
Alors pourquoi Luigi est toujours le joueur 2 ?
Putain ça m'saoule, Mario fait des couv'
Pendant que Luigi est derrière en tout petit
Sa meuf s'appelle Peach : c'est l'nom d'une brioche
S'ils font un gosse, putain il sera méga moche
Mario a du talent ? Ce n'est pas si sûr
Vu qu'toutes ses cascades sont faites par une doublure
Tellement Mario pèse qu'il a sa figurine Pez
Il prend le melon, traîne avec Alain Delon
Il gère des gow', prend des cachets illégaux
Mais l'meilleur épisode, c'est quand j'l'ai vu pécho Toad
Toad:  Non, non, non, non. Non... On, on faisait...
Mario: Rien. On faisait rien... Ah j'ai bien fait pipi
Toad: Tu veux, tu veux... Tu veux venir ?
Luigi: Non merci...
[Refrain]L.U.I.G.I mon nom c'est Luigi ! Here we, here we go : c'est la fin de Mario [4x]
Tu ramasses toutes les pièces mais t'es pas milliardaire
Mario est locataire, Luigi est propriétaire !
J'suis propriétaire, Luigi est propriétaire ! [x3]
J'suis propriétaire
Luigi Babe !
Here we go ! Here we, Here we go ! Here we go ! [x2]
C'est la fin de Mario !
Abonne-toi à ma chaîne Youtube ! Fais-toi plaiz' ! Fais-toi un kiffe !
Clique !